what is it control Brittany yes Brittany  said that a control is something that  stays the same right so you're changing  only one thing in your experiment and  that is the the covering we're only  changing the covering therefore  everything else in our experiment has to  stay the same so you are going to figure  out with your team what is that list of  things that has to stay the same go yeah  actually so there's that's nine the  person who pushes the car that's nine  but then there's the eighth one that  you're missing the ramp she has ramped  you have position of rent that's two  different things it's ramp and position  of rent it's two different things so  that's nine actually so the ramp and the  position of the ramp are two separate  things why why is that two different  things is where you put it right the  position of the ramp is where you put it  on the books what's up good oh I didn't  sign